listen to me look at me right now pay
very close attention I am speaking
directly to you my name is markiplier
but this is important
this game is disgusting it is absolutely
100% gross because it is 100% absolutely
about poop but not just poop poop in
every shape form methodology physiology
like every way that you could think
about poop I believe that this game has
it in it I have not even played this
game I've only seen the trailer and the
only reason that I'm playing it is
because it looked goddamn hilarious and
yes I was going to be poop jokes but I'm
warning you ahead of time because I am
trying to prepare you even now you're
rolling your eyes go okay mark all right
whatever
oh no listen this game he's going to
take a lot of forged it's going to take
a lot of investment and if you are not
prepared for this right now please leave
just go go on your day because what
you're looking at on those screens are
not legs
those are butt cheeks and I'm about to
present button that's probably going to
change my life forever
I warned you so if you're sticking with
me you're sticking with me through the
whole thing you don't walk away halfway
through because oh no I'm grossed out
now no you leave now or you leave never
you are in this with me or you're
without me and if you're with me you
need to show it show me your dedication
hit that dingdong like button because if
I'm telling you there's gonna be people
that are just gonna be like ah whatever
I did girls I'm out here no you're with
me and you're here the long-term and if
you're with me show me I smashed
like button drop a deuce on that sweet
like button and let's do this
if I have to suffer through this it's
good to know that you guys are brave
enough to suffer through this with me
I'm sorry I'm just a floating ass
oh I'm upside down now I am literally
just move no I can't move I can't even
move oh boy what am i doing
okay whoa hey well I think I may have
found a way you know never mind I don't
like it as much as I thought I might
what oh oh we didn't even start we were
just at the menu we have temporal
leakage voyage on septic seas things
that go dump in my [ __ ] what is that
incorporeal ascension a love that grew
in night soil the longest I want to go
with things that go dump in the night
cuz that sounds nice and terrifying and
I feel like maybe oh wait enter to go
back space to begin okay whatever
experimental food stores Gribble's seem
to have developed some sort of hierarchy
they are interested in the main subject
for unknown reasons a scouting party is
inbound
just how smart are these foodstuffs
what's okay here we go
this reminds me of the great poop
mountain in Conker's Bad Fur Day for the
day Conker's Bad Fur Day sorry I was
just trying to not throw up and the
thing about this is if you go check out
the trailer for this game you would
actually be incredibly impressed there's
a trailer for this game is quite
impressive and I don't know what I'm
looking at
[Music]
Balthus will lead us to Liberty his plan
cannot fail I see it the Gateway
I smell gas in the air what what am i
what am i my poop goblin what am i the
foodstuff Gribble's what is going on
this is so weird
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god hate it hate it hate
it hate it so much
what duh
so I [ __ ] with that that was the
scariest thing I've ever seen in any
game ever
is it a poof game it's in a [ __ ] poop
game
I don't know I don't know where I am I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
what I'm trying to do here
what am I trying to what is that what is
what the flying [ __ ] duck is that oh
why did we come here
what have I done what have you committed
to and you can't leave now you made a
promise you promise okay oh no oh no oh
okay never mind okay do I turn is it
it's dirt is it stirred Oh God
[Music]
hell I live this is real life
this is game is this game real life is a
guillotine family fun machine okay
apparently on the baby in the crib I
don't know what's going on there why are
things floating in zero g
[Music]
aren't then McGowan's will be coming
over any minute for bridge and bayleaf
entrails are all over the ceiling then
jump it's on the new gas boy just ten
pumps of the beacon will light driving
back those terrible
[Music]
oh oh oh I don't even know I don't
understand Oh always I cuz I don't know
[Music]
I feel I feel like I've stepped into a
wormhole hell do I have to push these
buttons whoa okay I did that oh I can
wiggle my butt cheeks with me cue
iniki's I don't understand I don't
understand I don't understand what's
happening why it's happening I don't
understand anything is this helping is
this hurting I see something I don't
know what I see
frankly I'd I don't understand oh oh
okay okay
all right I guess I gotta fight him back
oh oh oh whoa whoa oh my god oh oh oh
great googly-moogly I think I just gotta
fight him back but oh my god who's Gary
Oh Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe I have no
idea I don't understand I'm at a
complete loss of everything this is
simultaneously the most disturbing and
most confusing
okay just disturbing it's it's
simultaneously disturbing and just
disturbing I am pooping into the mat
open mouths of I'm frozen it's frozen I
think I am I are we we just I think I
made my way back to the main menu
that was totally seizing up there I'm
gonna try to go back into that one I
guess I don't think I got to the end of
it I think my problem was I tried to
press the diary button which I didn't
know it could be a problem
ohayo you're here early so they're
talking about they're talking about like
what's happening here for some reason
this is like a common thing and uh a
little unsure as to why but apparently
it is a common thing okay goodbye
goodbye goodbye farewell farewell
farewell farewell okay
alright do we have another on the way oh
I think I think there's someone at the
window but I'm pushing them back I think
I guess like most creatures they don't
like being cooped upon or have poop
rocketed at them at very high speeds oh
my god what is that what is that Oh what
is that I don't know what that is oh I
just see it alright see it though
alright by me it is behind me but I
don't know what it is oh oh it's like
some giant jiggly baby head the weird
thing is that the thing I don't like in
the thing I never wanted to happen in my
life when I was playing this game is to
get used to it but I think I'm starting
to get used to it oh I wanted to get
closer so I can see it but I then again
I actually kind of don't wobble horrible
horrible too close too close I get the
picture Oh horrible oh no oh no too
close
Oh too close too close too close Oh
too close the monster goes to go Oh too
close too close so close I think he got
a poop in their mouth which is I don't
know why I didn't think of it before
I was trying to poop in their eyes cuz
you know I thought that would be a thing
that demons in the dark would not want
hope in their eyes it got quiet I think
I've had this permanent grimace on my
face I don't think I'm ever gonna be
able to recover from it mom and dad I
hope you're proud of your baby boy oh
that's that's not
okay okay and it all comes crumbling
back down okay I don't know what your
job is but I don't think it did it very
well if you're that kind of defense
thing that was supposed to save me from
all this look I don't think what I
hadn't died because we oh no can't move
look I didn't know what I was getting
into
we struck oil oh oh no that's not oil
okay Berea College
Christmas dinner
that's how
I heard his parents came into town from
Cleveland I thought John was raised by
the state don't think so they came into
town last fall
keep them himself just like mama did hey
Britt yeah Connie John was overseas for
two years and those two boys couldn't
have been more than a few months old
when he got back right and Johnny said
that he didn't know that she was
pregnant
that's all he ever said on the matter
all I know I guess he doesn't say too
much anymore and killed Brentford swears
up and Hank she's in the other latest
our caring for another young man same
time she's real ugly with a big face
they hadn't seen her since age I lived a
strange guy didn't let's take it back
again
no killing what'd she do to that house
all those years while John was away you
don't think those boys had anything to
do with the accident you yeah Molly
could have been messing around town but
she know now I couldn't have no money
file to ceiling fan cut in draft damn
things or dead traitors where is she
tonight I think you took the day off
said he wasn't feeling too well and
there's no said he was going home what
others
you know the chief not since she came
back from the war yet maybe was just in
those Frenchie's a little too long now
what he said Oh something about their
wing at the Mauna Gateway of Magnum
Bellucci house that was about it rich
what I faded he said something about
their median our dominican gateway oh
well you know is it house that should
give us cause to were you thinking yeah
he still got the co shop I suppose
probably just still needs to readjust
hell my cousins hadn't said a damn word
since in the years of the war least
Chiefs been productive you know what
would all those crafts in arts I got
Helen Rhonda says his mother knows
wandering around town square kicker is
it is the old lass been dead for 15
years now looks like the god damn depth
of Samba huddle at Hawkins again it's
that ground rain too many strange things
come on huh
what what okay what what why what what
what what what what what what what what
what I spent all that time listening to
that exposition and you are just going
to zombie attack me what what what I
didn't I have no idea what the hell's it
was trying to be a dentist something
about the demonic portal underneath an
outhouse apparently that was all by
design okay
back in the baby crib baby oh oh oh oh
it's a wagon oh I'm in a wagon oh boy
but but in a wagon and apparently those
guys got killed by a zombies
what about Gribble's oh whoa whoa hey
whoa what's happening what's getting all
goopy over here I don't know why I'm
here or what I'm supposed to be doing I
don't understand anything all these
intricate storylines are coming together
all over the but they're all coming
together because of a but that's that's
like at the end of the day this is all
like happening around a but there's way
too much plot why is it all featured
around button Boop this could be
anything but button Boop what am i doing
where am I going
I'm lost I'm a child wandering around or
wagon or maybe I'm not a child maybe I'm
just a butt oh is that a door I can go
through yes oh it is nope no thank you
no just big big big no to that straight
it's allotted we're the invaders not
them
we're borrowing
these are
but they cannot see the truth
and that's how
okay-y who's getting full of topical
over there in the poop game this is a
poop last poop camp my plate was just
poop in my soup
thanks unless when I played and yet Here
I am in it in an among the sleep style
game about a butt baby and just havin
having a nice old time and a whack going
around pooping on things and then
everything's getting horrible and the
world is being taken over by Gribble's
oh no no that's not what I wanted
I'm gonna go back to the menu because I
I'm literally like I'm you I have no
answers you have no I have nothing but
questions there's there's nothing good
I mean it's good I that's the problem
like it's good that's the problem it's
it kicked out why why is it good
why is there a story that I want to know
barb in his Boop this is make any sense
how do I do this one oh ma and oppa
seven years one months three days 12
hours three minutes 23 seconds since
last confirmed concession to HQ fan Iran
structure semi-stable tangent strains
still strong even producing fluctuations
independent streams unable to receive
measurements subject alive still living
with unauthorised recipient Foster's
please advised s Wan what Oh Oh No let's
go to Omaha nope ah
Oh this was that it moved on to the next
chapter
oh it's all a continuing story then I
[ __ ] miss some context oh maybe I
should have been a little more cognizant
of the fact that it was it is supposed
to be an order I know I don't understand
why there were little gremlins alright
let's go to the mother dumb pissed of
course subject in question required
unauthorized displacement relocation of
high-profile variable inbound
unregistered stork unit generation two
with unknown operator coordinates 12 by
eighty nine by ninety eight by eight
nine one nine 109 Delta group okay
mother dumb pissed clown cometh
nope mother dumbest we're going to
mother dumb perceive this is where I
went wrong I started in the middle and
everything was weird now it's gonna move
[Music]
Nazis its Nazis
it doesn't make sense us for Gonzaga
well who are we not Z's why was I his
neighbor try to take out Hitler why am i
about
generator time you begin the splitter
going 100 Eastern December 1st 1917
secretary pro convergence with prime of
usually dating you've got you know
you've been posting the boys and
Prevention won't disturb the first one
physically
[Music]
oh I'm innocent I don't even have a head
to shoot guy-guy surrender I've got both
cheeks way up oh boy
Jai do you like it jiggle as though as
you want okay I am so good deuced
I have never been more confused
okay I think I get it now I think I'd
makes perfect sense I am a time
traveling but and I am I was causing
problems by trying to alter the past and
they caught me and now they were about
to punish me but then they got
interrupted by another time traveler who
is not about but probably has one what
was that why do I have a shotgun whoa ah
no occupied that's a bit of a dumb laugh
Oh where's my shotgun
[Music]
I do I was pooping policies boom bang I
[ __ ] do that
[ __ ] okay okay I got oh okay
you have so much to tell me hey oh I see
nice oh no I see okay I was supposed to
ah I get it I accidentally let him in by
not latching it there's some Dom man and
I'm also a but today all right I got
that I can't shoot you apparently I just
keep pooping but one of these days you
must do what let's do what Oh
that don't look good no which what
happened to your baby
oh no oh there's a demon it uh I got
poop I don't know oh I don't know Oh
[Music]
okay I don't know what that was all
about I'm so sorry I don't understand
this game was running some butter beat
the clown oh I don't want the clone oh
no I know I know I don't want the clown
oh no okay okay all right okay
this game is beyond me this game is
beyond my ability to comprehend this
game is so intricately deep that Mike my
my my human mind can't wrap my head
around its but logic I I've got nothing
I've got no words you've been on this
journey with me because you made a
promise and I fear I've led you astray
or led you down the path of
enlightenment because frankly I don't
know which this game is so beyond
anything I could have ever expected out
of it and I've only scratched the
surface I jumped ahead didn't know what
happened
jumped up beginning don't know what
happened I could jump to the end if I
still not know what happened so I'm
gonna leave it here for now cuz maybe
you guys want to see more of this been
in again maybe you really don't want to
see more of this stuff what if I stream
this game what if I did
oh I have no idea but that's the thing
right the voice acting is really good
the story seems integrate and it doesn't
seem like just bumbling nonsense it
seems like there's actually something
there
I could literally start to be something
together here but I don't want to huh
anyway I'm an analyst here I'm gonna try
to reclaim my sanity you guys let me
know what you thought of this down in
the comments below
but I'm sure the comments have just been
a cavalcade of what
flying [ __ ] the whole time I can't say I
had a bad dump I cannot say my jaw has
been on the floor the whole time but
honestly this game is not bad for a
flying but there are deals in poop it
surprisingly not bad so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed it remember Australia we're
coming to you New Zealand check the
description for dates
mr. Dan we're coming your way check the
description and if you made it through
this through the trial and pain and
suffering leave a like to show that you
made it through and you were dedicated
enough cuz there's going to be those
that failed along the way but you were
strong you made it all the way to the
end and thank you for that without you
here by my side I couldn't have survived
this so thank you everybody someone for
watching check out the other non poop or
poop related games that I played and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]